793 in Lindisfarne monastery here is a
little bit on fire it was set on fire by
a group of raiders commonly known as
Vikings who saw the wealthy poorly
defended monastery is easy pickings
which to be fair it was the raid on
Lindisfarne is often considered to be
the beginning of the period of European
history known as the Viking Age because
here after the number of Seaborn raids
and the amount of Viking activity across
Europe increased dramatically so who
were these Vikings
well they originated from Scandinavia
what is now Denmark Norway and Sweden be
aware that these weren't a single group
of people they had different social and
religious practices and were more than
happy to raid each other when it was
profitable speaking of raiding Viking
has become synonymous with raider but
it's important to note that many Vikings
were simply seaborne trade is a most
stayed at home farming farming in
Scandinavia was a mixed bag and in the
north of the Viking territories it was
practically impossible because cold
southern denmark had parts of norway and
sweden were actually quite good for
farming but population growth than their
other means such as fishing was needed
for sustenance the difficult climate and
terrain of Scandinavia also made
governing the people there very
difficult Kings often ruled with the
light touch since commanding someone who
was on an island over a mountain or on
the other side of a dense forest wasn't
that easy
that said force was one of the primary
ways of securing royalty along with
rewarding followers with gifts there
were some areas in Scandinavia which
were pretty good in terms of resources
and it was around these areas the power
coalesced the history of Scandinavia
during the 9th century shrouded in myth
and legend and frankly there is very
little that can be said as definite fact
just a quick note on names to will be
using the names Danish Swedish and Norse
Norwegian but be aware that the borders
in Scandinavia weren't settled and that
people simply lived wherever was
habitable anyway in the 9th century
Norway named after the sea route along
its coast the northern way was the land
of many petty kingdoms who rose and fell
as they vied for dominance that is until
a certain King Harald fairhair shows up
around 872 but again no one knows for
sure
it was he who established a power base
over the course of a few decades gained
over lordship over the north and then
defeated the confederation of petty
kings at the Battle of half his field
and it was after his victory that Harald
declared himself to be the first king of
the Norwegians in what is now Denmark
the ninth century isn't much clearer and
actually the name Denmark wasn't used
until about the Year 930
it is known though from the records of
the Frankish Empire of Charlemagne that
some of the lords who lived there will
do the great deal of power and that the
Danes were noted fighters in Sweden
after the spare people who lived here
there is loads of evidence about what
happened down to the tiniest minutiae oh
wait no there isn't what can be said for
sure though is that the people that live
there live mostly in these areas and
that the spare made a great deal of
contact with their neighbors across the
Baltic Sea also shockingly it was
divided into petty kingdoms it's also
known that the Swedes made regular
contact with the Sami people from the
north and it's likely that some of their
religious practices were adopted from
them so whilst not a great deal is known
about Scandinavia itself during this
period the people from there certainly
made an impact in other places the ninth
century saw widespread raiding across
Western Europe such as those on frankerq
between 840 and 850 the Franks fought to
fight their coasts and rivers which
forced the Vikings to turn their
attention elsewhere to the British Isles
the British Isles had been subject to
Viking raids throughout most of the
ninth century in its wealth attracted
many mostly from Denmark to come and
take it
the 860 saw the landing of the great
heathen army in Britain which devastated
many of the anglo-saxon kingdoms there
have made a lot of money doing so the
Norse those from Norway raided their way
across the northern and western coasts
of Scotland and ended up at the island
of Ireland where they did yet more
raiding the reasons behind Viking
raiding are fiercely debated and range
from a lack of arable land back home to
cope with population growth to
honor-based or semi religious reasons
more on that in a bit the great heathen
army soon changed from one of raiding to
one of conquest and in short time they
conquered and settled this area
subsequently called the Danelaw
the norse conquered most of the northern
islands across the British Isles and
also settle places like Dublin and Cork
which soon became important slave
trading hubs to the north lay the
uninhabited island of Iceland Iceland
was settled by a man called in golfer an
arson who settled Reykjavik in 874 and
unlike the rest of Europe no one lived
there and so settlement was done without
violence the norse also settled the
Faroe Islands here but no one knows when
for sure
expansion wasn't limited to the west or
to the north the East also saw a great
deal of Viking mostly Swedish activity
the Vikings moved south settling raiding
and trading until they came to the Black
Sea and made contact with a very wealthy
Byzantine Empire there's a lot of
questions concerning the manner of
Scandinavian settlement in Eastern
Europe and to what extent they dominated
the region however they were definitely
deeply involved in the politics of the
area and it made the Vikings their very
wealthy the Vikings brought great change
with them to the places they settled
generally speaking the Vikings were much
more urbanized in the expanded major
settlements like York Dublin and Kia
which became deeply intertwined with
European trade the social changes they
brought with them vary depending on the
region but the primary area of conflict
between the Vikings and those they
conquered was that of religion so the
Viking religion was a form of Germanic
paganism and is extremely complicated
there were many gods and not all Vikings
worshiped the same gods there were also
the nornes who determined a person's
unchangeable destiny and this idea of a
set fate was extremely important for
example if you were destined to die in
combat you would ideally go forth
looking for combat to approach your fate
bravely Christians have attempted to
convert people in Scandinavia for
centuries by this point ultimately to no
avail
in fact many Vikings recognized the
Christian desire to convert them and
went along with it for political gain
one such example was Rollo who in 911
after raiding frankerq was given this
land in Normandy which was probably the
land he was occupying he was officially
given it on two conditions prevent
raiding from other Vikings and of course
be baptized for many Vikings baptism was
a sincere act of conversion and for
others it was just the thing Christians
wanted you to do after they paid you off
in fact some Vikings complained that the
baptism they were just given wasn't as
nice as the last one
so back in Norway things were starting
to heat up Harald fairhair died around
9:30 his kingdom fell apart and what
remained went to his son Eric the first
better known as Eric blood axe he was
kicked out in 933 by his brother the new
King Haakon also known as hack and the
good and Eric went off to rule Dublin in
Northumbria hakam was as his name
suggests a pretty good King and sought
to strengthen his realm he was also a
Christian and attempted to convert his
subjects but once he realized they were
pretty annoyed with the whole Jesus
thing he himself went back to worshiping
the Norse gods by the mid 10 centuries
m-mark was still divided into many
kingdoms and it was this one the kingdom
of Jutland which was ruled by a man
called gone the old Gorn being old died
in 958 and was succeeded by his son
Harald better known as Harald Bluetooth
Harald would go on to conquer the
entirety of the now gormless Denmark
which is one of the reasons he's so
famous the other is that he converted to
Christianity this was after he attempted
to rate the Holy Roman Empire under Otto
the first in 960 Harald lost and thus
was made to convert but be aware that
there were already many Christians in
Denmark such as those who had returned
from the Danelaw
so one thing you'll have noticed
throughout this episode is that I keep
saying how we don't know much for
certain so how do we know anything about
the period the primary sources are often
from outside of Scandinavia like those
from England or Frank here but there are
two important Scandinavian
sources the first were the gelling
stones which were inscribed stones which
were made at jelling the old capital of
Jutland the major ones were made by
Harald Bluetooth to celebrate both the
unification of Denmark and its
conversion to Christianity the other
source is the sagas mostly from Iceland
which were narrative stories written
hundreds of years after the events they
spoke of hence why half of what is
written in the sagas is seen as semi
legendary not strictly trustworthy so
back to Denmark the rest of Harold's
reign did see him to pose King Haakon
the good and replace him with his nephew
Harold gray cloak gray cloak did
basically nothing except die in 917 so
howard declared himself to be the king
of norway - this would mark the high
point of Harold's reign since the 986 he
was deposed by his son Sweyn Forkbeard
Swain forbids reign is frankly a bit of
a mystery after taking the throne he
appears to have either raided England
and Scotland for about a decade or was
exiled there by his Nobles in the
Swedish King Eric the victorious in 95
he appears to have lost Norway to olaf
Trigg verson who undertook converting it
to christianity with some success
slightly after this the Swedish King
Olaf's Kurt kanoon would do the same
thing in his realm again the problem
with Swedish history at this point is
that nobody can say for sure what was
going on it's pretty certain that the
sphere had conquered the Geats to the
south but their northern borders are
basically unknown up in Iceland a man
called Eric the red was banished for
manslaughter in the late 10th century
shortly afterwards he stumbled across
and then settled Greenland Eric's son
Leif Ericson would then in the year 1001
discover North America so take that
Columbus there were some temporary
settlements in North America but for
some reason they didn't last and thus
North America wouldn't see European
contact again for nearly half a
millennium Swain would at some point
return to Denmark and after the death of
trick verson in the year 1000 he
reclaimed Norway he went back and forth
raiding England for many years and in
1013 he managed to seize it for himself
and become King there thus beginning
England's royal house of Denmark he died
the next year and his son Knut would
begin his rule in England two years
later by 1020 a cannot road all of these
lands now known as the North Sea Empire
cannot died in 1035 and his kingdoms
were divided in fighting broke out the
kingship of Cunha would be used by his
descendant the king of norway Harald
Hardrada in 1066 landed in Northumbria
with the intent to take England's crown
for himself this went pretty well for
his enemy since harada got himself
killed
1066 and the death of Harald Hardrada is
considered by many to mark the end of
the Viking Age the reason for this is
largely because the
King Nations were part of the Christian
world and were no longer able to raid
with impunity or even defeat their
enemies Denmark Sweden and Norway were
Christian kingdoms just like any other
and so there were rules you couldn't
simply take a kingdom now just because
you wanted it you couldn't turn up and
raid murder or enslave your fellow
Christians anymore that's not to say
that nobody from these places ever
raided again they did and the Norwegian
holdings in the British Isles would
remain theirs until the 15th century the
legacy is the Viking Age is extremely
far reaching this period did not settle
the issue of Scandinavian borders but it
taught the rest of Europe that
Scandinavia was not something he could
ignore anymore obviously one legacies
that it spread the Scandinavian culture
to the Faroe Islands Iceland and
Greenland they changed language and the
politics of much of Western Europe and
whilst hot rodder had failed to subdue
England it was William the
great-great-great grandson of rolla who
would conquer it immediately afterwards
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching and a special
thanks to Thomas guest Strich Adam
Harvey Winston Cawood and James
Bissonnette if you'd like to learn more
about the Viking Age there are some book
recommendations in the description below
you